SPEAKER 1: Let's see how
to deploy an ASP.NET app
on Google Compute Engine using
Cloud Tools for Visual Studio.
First, go to Tools, and
Extensions and Updates
and install Google Cloud
Tools for Visual Studio.
Once installed, go to Google
Cloud Tools and Manage Accounts
and add your Google
Cloud account.
Now go to Google Cloud Explorer
and select your project.
And then create a
new ASP.NET instance.
This opens Cloud Launcher, where
you can deploy a Compute Engine
instance with Windows
Server, IaaS, SQL Server,
and ASP.NET framework installed.
Once Compute Engine
instance is ready,
create a new Windows user.
Finally, right-click
on your ASP.NET app
and select Publish
to Google Cloud.
Select Compute Engine, choose
the VM instance and the Windows
account that you want
to use to publish.
In a few seconds, your app will
be deployed to Compute Engine.